Japan the land of cherry blossoms Sushi
and haggis
you heard that right this is the story
of how Scotland's national dish made its
way six thousand miles around the world
to the Land of the Rising Sun
this tale begins in 2014 when Japanese
food lovers Yoko and kits went on
holiday to London but they were worried
about one food
foreign
street vendor specializing in haggis
Toasties it's hard to pinpoint the
actual moment when
we had the sort of hagas toasty epiphany
I think it was my idea I'm so Cleveland
it is mine but growing up we would eat
haggis quite a lot in the northeast of
Scotland it made sense to make this
grilled cheese toasty more Scottish by
just adding haggis the sort of
ubiquitous national dish of Scotland
and it wasn't long until Yoko and kits
were trying this new dishes
[Music]
so Paddy what actually is haggis haggis
is lamb or four mixed with oats and
spices so you've got like heart lung and
liver of the Lamb mixed with oats and
spices it's then cooked inside the
lining of the Sheep's stomach it's hard
to make that sound appetizing
I generally call it like a like a lamb
sausage spicy lamb sausage is a nice
entry-level way to describe haggis
foreign
visited the stall on Broadway Market in
2014 and they just really loved the idea
of the Haggis toasty and just it overall
thought it would really work well in her
hometown of Tokyo because Yoko and kids
couldn't import The Haggis they had to
learn how to make it from scratch
because yeah
the Land of the Rising Sun had never
seen such a creation
and it wasn't long until Carol and Paddy
wandered in on the action as well we're
off the plane we met them within maybe
two hours and the first thing we ate was
the Macbeth I guess toasty it was like
identical it may as well be made in our
kitchen here
you see you know someone six thousand
miles away doing the same and making a
living out of it it was hugely emotional
yeah this is like our little baby at
this stage
[Music]
make sure you like subscribe and share
with friends